- When I first started
climbing, I started going
to all types of climbing
events, and I noticed
I was the only person of color.
I went home and I was
online, and I searched,
do black people rock climb,
'cause I was really curious
and my goal was to try and find
where are all the black climbers?
I found these forums that said,
"Black people don't climb,"
and I wanted to prove them wrong.
(soft acoustic guitar music)
Growing up, going into
the woods, going outdoors,
it was something that
black people didn't do,
you know, at least that's what I was told.
In New York City, you didn't really have
too many options for sports.
It was either basketball,
football, or baseball
if you were close enough to a park.
I wanted to bring a fourth
option to my community
and that's rock climbing.
I co-founded Brothers of Climbing,
an organization formed to
tackle the lack of diversity
in rock climbing and to help promote
and encourage people of color
and underrepresented groups
to get in the outdoors.
It's for men, women, anyone.
If you feel underrepresented in climbing,
you belong with us.
When the group formed,
there were only three of us,
and now there's dozens of us,
and that's a great feeling.
In New York City we
host a monthly meet up.
Across the country we
wanna host a festival
and then just other
events in other cities.
There are many reasons why
there's a lack of representation
in the sport of rock climbing.
One reason is there's not too many mentors
within our community teaching
and spreading the knowledge.
When I grew up, I never had that.
Also, the industry doesn't do a great job
showing the diversity
that is in the sport.
You can open up a catalog
and you won't find
a person of color in it.
You know, the minute you get out
there and you start doing it
and you realize how easy
it is, something clicks
and then you say, "I can do this.
"I can do this, I'm doing it."
I'm doing it and I want
other people to realize that.
(mellow chiming music)
(bell chiming)